بعض العنف كلمه او بها يبدا هذا بعض ما
تفعله كلمات التحريض
تعتقد جمعتنا انها ازمه خطيره لان طلابنا
يتعرضون لترهيب ذي طابع عنصري المضايقات
والاعتداءات مستمره في وسائل النقد العام
والشوارع كما يقدم الملاك على طردهم من
المنازل المستاجره
انا لذلك ان يتوقف يقوله هؤلاء انهم
حقوقيون وناشطون تستهجن مسيرتهم في تونس
العاصمه ما بدا لهم خطاب رسميا عنصريا
تجاه فئات من المهاجرين جاءوا البلد
مقيمين او عابرين يصف المحتجون استهداف
المهاجرين الافارقه غير النظاميين بالعمل
الفاشل ويطالبون السلطات باستجابه
الانسانيه لتسويه اوضاع اعداد منهم
يعني
[موسيقى]
الى الحقل الاقتصادي والاجتماعي باش يتم
ايضا من من الاماكن يسكنوا فيها يمكن
في الشارع فما فما حملات امنيه مكثفه
كانما فتحت هنا جبهه توتر جديده تونس في
غنى عنها نشطه اخيرا في الفضائيين الواقعي
والافتراضي حاله من التجاذب بينما يدعم
وجود طالب هجره افارقه من دول جنوب
الصحراء في تونس وما يرفض توافدهم وبدا ان
الخطاب الخارج من قصر قرطاج زاد الامر
سوءا تحدث الرئيس قيس سعيد اخيرا عن ضروره
وضع حد لتدفق المهاجرين غير النظاميين من
دول افريقيا جنوبيه الصحراء الى البلاد
على وجه السرعه ولم يكن مفهوما وصفه وصول
اعداد كبيره منهم بانه مؤامره لتغيير
التركيبه الديموغرافيه في تونس
لم تتاخر ادانته فوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
لتصريحات سعيد التي وصفتها بالعنصريه تجاه
مهاجرين افارقه في تونس
قالت في بيان انه جرى ابلاغ ممثل تونسي
بصدمه المفوضيه وقالقها من استهداف
مواطنين افارقه بغض النظر عن وضعهم
القانوني في البلاد هل تمت هنا ما اسيء
فهمه ذاك ما تراه الخارجيه التونسيه التي
ترفض ما ورد في بيان المفوضيه الافريقيه
من عبارات واتهامات قالت انه لا اساس لها
من الصحه
واعتبرت الوزاره ان موقف المفوضيه بني على
فهم خاطئ لمواقف السلطات التونسيه
تصحيح اخر تنفيذ الداخليه التونسيه
الانباء عن حملات توقيف تستهدف المهاجرين
من دول افريقيا جنوبيه الصحراء وتدعو لعدم
الانسياق وراء ما تصفه بالمزايدات
والاتهامات التي تقوم بها جهات تحركها
اغراض مختلفه
لا تحدد تلك الجهات لكن الجهات الحقوقيه
والمدنيه في تونس تجمع على التنديد بخطاب
الكراهيه كما تصفه تجاه المهاجرين
الافارقه في حين ان جهات يمنيه متطرفه في
اوروبا التي يقصدها هؤلاء المهاجرون عاده
راقت لها تصريحات سعيد